ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاشي ملفنا الاول
في اعلان هو الاول من نوعه من قبل الصين
وبالتزامن مع مرور عام على اندلاع الحرف
اوكرانيا كشفت بكين عن مبادره لاحلال
السلام وبين الترحيب والتشكيك تباينت ردود
فالخارجيه الروسيه عبرت عن مشاطرتها
لرؤيتها للتسويه مع التاكيد على وجوب
اعتراف كياف بالحقائق الجديده المتصله
بالاراضي الاوكرانيه التي اعلنت موسكو
ضمها اما الطرف الثاني هو المباشر في
الازمه اي اوكرانيا فعرض رئيس الاوكراني
فحصانيه بكين عبر بحث المبادره مع نظيره
الصيني الموقف الامريكي عبر عنه الرئيس
بايدن الذي وصف المبادره بغير العقلانيه
من جانبها عبارات رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه عن احتياج اوروبا لمزيد من
البراهين بان الصين فعلا لا تساعد روسيا
على حساب اوكرانيا وفيما بدا انه تناقض في
تصريحات المفوضيه الاوروبيه قال المستشار
الالماني قال ان المبادره الصينيه تتضمن
امورا ايجابيه وصائبه وفي اطار تفاوت ردود
الافعال حول المبادره اشار الرئيس الفرنسي
الى ان السلامه ممكن فقط بوقف العدوان
الروسي وبانسحاب القوات واحترام السياده
الاقليميه في اوكرانيا
مبادره بكين لانهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا
وقف القتال والصراع احترام سياده كافه
الدول نبدو عقليه الحرب البارده
اطلاق مفاوضات السلام في اوكرانيا وحل
الازمه الانسانيه حمايه المدنيين والاسرى
الحفاظ على سلامه المحطات النوويه
ضمان تصدير الحبوب
التقليل من المخاطر الاستراتيجيه
ضمان استقرار سلاسل الصناعه والامداد
التخلي عن فرض العقوبات احاديه الجانب
[موسيقى]
اعاده الاعمار بعد انتهاء النساء
الصين مستعده للمساعده في اعاده الاعمار
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من الرياض
الهامليه الصحافه الصيني اهلا بك من
اورلاندو عبر سكايبتوم حرب ريسو تحالف
الامريكيه شرق الاوسطى للديمقراطيه اهلا
بكم مع ضيوفي من الكرام واسمحالي ان ابدا
من اورلاندو معك سيد توم سيد توم في
الواقع بالعوده لتصريحات الجانب الامريكي
فما يخص هذه المبادره الصينيه يقول الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن بان هذا هذه المبادره في
شكلها وفي مضمونها غير عقلانيه هكذا وصفها
بايدن هل تعتقد بان هذا الوصف لان البنود
لا تليق او لا تتفق مع رؤيه واشنطن ام لان
واشنطن لا ترى في الصين وسيطا محايدا
اولا مرحبا لك
المشاهدين يعني بالفعل هي كانت خيبه امل
لدينا عندما ذهب الرئيس بايدن ولم يطرح اي
خطه سلام يعني فقط ذهب وبعد سنه من الحرب
ودعم الموقف الاوكراني
وماديا ولوجستيا وكذلك ذهب الى بولندا
وكان له كذلك موقف حاسم بدون ان يطرح اي
عمليه السلام واذ تفاجانا بطريقه عمليه
السلام من الجانب
الصيني هلا بدون شك يجب ان يستطرح عمليه
السلام ربما كان يجب ان تطرح في الامم
المتحده لان ام الامم المتحده انشات لمنع
اي اي حروب ولتخفيض من كميه الحروب ولا
الحوارات ولكن في هذه الحاله بالفعل يعني
فشل الامم المتحده مما اضطر قبل الصين
كانت تركيا حتى السعوديه حاولوا طرح عمليه
السلام ولكن حتى الرئيس زلينسكي قبل بنوعا
ما من عمليه طرح السلام التي قبل قبل على
الاقل بالجلوس مع نظيره الصيني لمناقشته
بخصوص هذا الموضوع ولكن بالعوده حضرتك لما
قلته حضرتك وكانك تتحدث عن انزعاجا بداخل
الامريكي لان واشنطن كان المنتظر بان
واشنطن هي التي تقدم بهذه المبادره
فسبقتها الصين في ذلك هذا ما يزعج
الامريكيين باختصار تكرمت
وا تقريبا نص المبلغ فلذلك الامر هنالك
ملل من الكونجرس الامريكي بشقه الجمهوري
والديمقراطي وخاصه الجمهوريين اليوم هم
بيدهن الكون الامريكي فربما اذا المساعدات
توقفت
موقف الاوكراني سيتغير
وربما نصل الى حل وسلام في اوكرانيا سيد
الهام هل تعتقد حضرتك ومن خلالك الاوساط
السياسيه الصينيه بانه دون موافقه واشنطن
او على الاقل هذا ما يظهر من خلال
التصريحات يمكن البناء على هكذا مبادره
بالنسبه الى المبادره الصينيه
للازمه الاوكرانيه او نقول يعني مبادئ
الصيني
للازمات الاوكرانيه في الحقيقه يعني من
بدايه الشيء ما في حاجه الى موافقه
الولايات المتحده بسبب بسببين اول شيء في
الحقيقه الولايات المتحده ليس يشارك بشكل
مباشر ولكن قد تم بدعم عسكري بشكل كبير
الى
جهه من الجهتين المتنازعه في الازمه
الاوكرانيه وبالاضافه الى ذلك نظرا لتوتر
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه ففي الحقيقه
من الصعب ان يتفق الجانبين على ما يسمى
بالمبادره سلام او في كثير من القضايا
الدوليه ولكن اريد ان اشير الى ان هناك
نقطه مهمه جدا بالنسبه للصين فاول شيء
يعني هذه
المبادره من ضمنها المبادئ الاساسيه
لميثاق الامم المتحده
في ثاني شيء يعني
تتعهد الصين بتقديم الدعم اللازم
للجانبين كله من روسيا واوكرانيا وخاصه
تتعهد ببذل جهود
توقف عن الحرب الاوكرانيه او العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه لذلك يعني لا اعرف لماذا
اللقالات جهه الامريكيه بان هذه مبادره
غير عقلاني في الحقيقه الذي ينتقد بهذه
المبادره هي هو الغير عقلاني
ما رايك سيد توم ضيف يقول اولا بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه منخرطه في
الحرب حتى وان لم تكن على الميدان ولكنها
تصلح بطريقه مكثفه الجانب الاوكراني فلا
يمكن بشكل من الاشكال ان تكون ان تكون
وسيطا محايدا يقول كذلك بان العلاقات
المتشنجه بين الفتره والاخرى بين الصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه قد تكون سببا
من اسباب هذا الرفض الامريكي ويضيف بان
راي واشنطن وموقفها لا يهم ان كان هناك
اجماع في المقابل على هذه المبادره
يعني هو بالنتيجه الموقف الامريكاني
سيتغير وخاصه نحن دخلنا
بمعركه الانتخابات الرئاسيه لل2021 سيكون
انتقادات كثيره ضد اداره الرئيس بايدن
واذا ستنتهي هنا هذا الشيء جيد ولكن
تراجع
القوى العظمى ومنها الولايات المتحده على
الساحه الدوليه هو بدا يشكك به الامريكيين
في الداخل بعد الانسحاب من افغانستان بعد
الجفاف الحاصل مع الدول العربيه
الوضع في اوكرانيا كل هذا اليوم يعني
الشعب الامريكاني بدا يتساءل فلذلك الامر
الكونغرس الامريكي عليه ان يلعب دورا حساس
واذا استطاع الجمهوريون بتوقيف اما تخفيف
المساعدات الى اوكرانيا فكل شيء سيتغير
بين الليله وضحاها على الساحه الاوكرانيه
اليوم الاوكرانيين عم ياخذوا حولها 200
مليار دولار
الدول الغربيه وخاصه الولايات المتحده
فاذا توقف جزء هذه المساعدات ماذا سيحصل
في اوكرانيا فلذلك الامر انا بتصور
المبادره الصينيه هي بالبدء جيده وخاصه
لوقف اطلاق النار وبدء المحادثات استئناف
المحادثات لعمليه سلام هذا شيء جيد فلذلك
الامر الالمان
والايطاليين تجاوبوا مع هذا الطرق
مبادره وعلينا متابعه هذه المبادره للوصول
الى حل كيف الحال هذا عندما نستانف عمليه
السلام والمحادثات
وخاصه وان الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل كما
يقال ولكن سيد الهام ليس هناك فقط الجانب
الامريكي الذي يعد موقفه مهما من هذه
المبادره هناك كذلك فعل اخر وهو الجانب
الاوروبي وهناك تخبط وكان البعض يقول هناك
تباينات حتى في المواقف الاوروبيه
بينما جهات اورو بيه تعتبر بان الصين لا
يمكن باي شكل ان تكون وسيط هناك جهات اخرى
تعتبر بان هذه المبادره ايجابيه ويمكن
العمل عليها الصين كيف تقرا هذا التباين
نعم فحضرتك على حاجه بان هذه المبادره
ومواقف اتجاه هذه المبادره
تعكس على
الاختلافات بين الولايات المتحده ودول
الاوروبيه وحتى البيع من بين من داخل
الدول الاوروبيه ففي الحقيقه اول شيء منذ
بدايه الازمه الاوكرانيه كان هناك خلافات
واضحه بين الولايات المتحده ودول
الاوروبيه وخاصه يعني نعرف بان
الدول الاوروبيه المانيه وفرنسا هي يعني
تخسر باكبر
الدرجه في هذه الازمه ازمه الاوكرانيه
بسبب ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه وايضا اسعار المواد الغذائيه
وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني من ضمن الترحيب من
قبل الدول الاوروبيه او قياده الدول
الاوروبيه ايضا نرى ان هناك مواقف يقول ان
الصين غير
للعب دوري الوساطه في ازمه الاوكرانيه
ولكن السؤال من هو المؤهل للعب دور
الوساطه في الحقيقه الصين دائما تتخذ
بموقف المحايد لم يقدم
الاوروبيه تقول علينا ان نتاكد اولا من ان
الصين لا تساعد روسيا على حساب
الاوكرانيين
فيبدو بان هناك يعني دلائل يجب على الصين
تقديمها لتضع نفسها في موقف الوسيط
المحايد الجهه الاوروبيه لا تعتقد كثيرا
بذلك
نعم ولكن في نفس الوقت قال رئيس الامريكي
بانه ليس لديهم الدليل على تقديم
المساعدات من قبل الجانب الصيني الى
الجانب الروسي ففي الحقيقه يعني هذا ايضا
كما قلت في البدايه يدل على الخلافات بين
الجانب الامريكي والجانب الاوروبي
وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني ان اتفق مع ضيفنا
من الاخر بان هذه المبادره بدايه جيده في
الحقيقه يعني منذ اندلاع الازمه
الاوكرانيه يعني علاوه عن الامم المتحده
لم نرى اي مبادره بشكل حقيقي ولم نرى اي
مبادره يعني قد تلقى باقبال واسع في
الحقيقه الصيني الان يعني بعد
هذه المبادره هناك نوعا ما من الترحيب من
قبل الجانب الاوكراني ايضا وايضا الجانب
الروسي يفتقرون بشكل جدي عن هذه المبادره
وفي الحقيقه نحن نعترف بان هذه المبادره
يعني المضامين
اساسيه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه ولكن نعرف
بان القضايا الدوليه وخاصه مثل ازمه
الاوكرانيه يعني لها اسباب تاريخيه كثيره
لذلك يعني في حاجه الى وقت طويل لحل هذه
المشاكل
مراقبون بان هذه المبادره قد تاتي بوقف
لاطلاق النار ولكن لا يمكن حل كل التفاصيل
التي تخص هذه الحرب الا في وقت اطول ربما
ولكنك اتيت على الخلافات الاوروبيه
الامريكيه وهنا السؤال حضرتك
هذه الخلافات تعلم حضرتك بانها تغذيها
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تتفاقم داخل
اوروبا يوما بعد يوم وهناك حديث عن امتعاث
اوروبي من هذا الموضوع هل يمكن ان نتحدث
عن مسانده للمبادره الاوروبيه بغض النظر
عن الموقف الامريكي يمكن ان نرى هذه
المعادله وان تنجح دون واشنطن
لا اكيد لا يمكن ان تنجح اي مبادره بدون
واشنطن
لانه واقفه مجلس الامن فيجب ان تشارك
الولايات المتحده ولكن تفكك الدول
الاوروبيه والاتحاد الاوروبي حال من يدعم
هذه المبادره ومن لا يدعمها وخاصه هنا في
الولايات المتحده هنالك فريق كبير اليوم
يحاول تخفيض الاموال الى اوكرانيا ربما
تكون اوراق ضغط على اداره بايدن ونقطه
ثانيه يعني في ايام الحرب البارده كان
هنالك وجهات نظر عديده من الادارات
السابقه
لوضع تفارق كبير بين
الكرملين وبيكين ولكن اليوم بعهد بايدن
يعني هذا الفرق الكبير كان اليوم عوض وحد
بسياسته
يعني المخبطه في اوروبا وحد العلاقات
الروسيه الصينيه وهذا ليست للاستلم لمصلحه
لا الاوروبيين وليس لمصلحه الامريكيه وعلى
كل سيبقى موضوعا للمتابعه وسنرى اين
ستحملنا هذه المبادره اذ كانت ستوقف اطلاق
النار او ستؤثر بشكل او باخر على هذه
الحرب اود شكركم الجزيل الشكر من الرياض
الهامليه الصحفي الصيني ومنطو توم حرب
رئيس تحالف الامريكيه الشرق اوسطى
للديمقراطيه شكرا لكما